there's a handful of big projects i  should be pushing right now that i'm  basically just saying until the book's  done i'm not gonna be able to do it you  don't set like hard deadlines on like  book completions or anything that's more  just like a hobby for free time if  anything acquisition.com does not need  the book like the book is for me but  either the book makes acquisition.com  less money i mean literally layla and i  were having conversations about this  last night i was just saying like i just  wanted to say thank you to her because i  know that there are things that i should  be doing right now that i'm not doing  because i want to write this book i'm  doing it for me i was like thanks for  giving me the space to do this because  like why do you have a business you have  a business so that you can have the  freedom to have options and for me it's  selfish i really like it and so i do it